في انتظار اي مواقف رسميه من القياده سواء
المدنيه او العسكريه الى حد الان لم يصدر
موقف رسمي صريح اتحدث عن الرئيس
الجميع هنا في اوكرانيا يركز عبر على موقع
او حساب عبر تيليجرام الحساب الذي يغرد
فيه كثيرا لم يصدر اي موقف رسمي الى حد
الان باستثناء موقف مستشاره ميخائيل الذي
قال ليله امس لحظات فقط بعد سقوط الطائره
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين متورط
وهو من قام باسقاط هذه الطائره وقال ايضا
زعيم او قائد مجموعه فانا
غبيا عندما صدق وعود الرئيس البيلاروس
الكسندر لوكاشينكو وقد امضى شخصيا على
وثيقه اعدامه وقال ايضا ان هذه العمليه
اريد من خلفها او من ورائها البعث برساله
الى كل المعارضه في روسيا والى كل الاجهزه
العسكريه الخاصه او الاجهزه شركات
العسكريه الخاصه انه لا سيده الا الكريبل
ولا قرار الا للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هذا عن الموقف الرسمي اتحدث الان
جعفر عن مواقف الاوكرانيين منذ اللحظات
الاولى التي بدات تتضارب فيها الاخبار حول
مقتل
بدت السعاده واضحه جدا على وجوه
الاوكرانيين كما تعلم احتفلوا ليله امس
بعيد العلم واليوم بعيد الاستقلال وتحدثت
مع اكثر من شخص وقال ليله او حينها اذا صح
الخبر سوف سوف تكون هديه كبيره من السماء
للاوكرانيين لماذا لان الاوكرانيين يعرفون
جيدا مجموعه فاجنر ويعرفون جيدا
ايضا تم الاعلان عنها او تاسست عام 2014
بدايه النزاع في اقليم
ومجموعه فاجنر كانت اولى
المجموعات التي دخلت العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف عندما بدات ما سماها حينها بوتين
بالعمليه العسكريه وكانت تحمل حسب التق
طبعا الاستخباراتيه الاوكرانيه هنا
المحليه وثيقه فيها مخطط لقتل الرئيس
الاوكراني
واكثر من 20 شخص من حكومته وكان ايضا على
راس هذه القائمه عمده
هذا حول بعض المواقف التي شاهدتها شاهدتها
سعاده عاربه وشاهد ايضا تحرك سريع لقوافل
السيارات سيارات المسؤولين على ما يبدو
انه كان هناك اجتماع عالي المستوى لا ادري
ان كان في الرئاسه او في مكان اخر لكن
الجميع ينتظر خروج زيلينسكي عن صمته وتحد
زيلينسكي لان الى حد الان لم يصدر الا
بيان عن الرئاسه مثل ما سبق وان قلت من
توقيع المستشار الشخصي اريد ان اتحدث ايضا
على السعاده لانه ليله امس لم يكن بامكان
الاوكرانيين ان يحتفلوا اكثر بسبب حظر
التجوال الذي يبدا بحوالي الساعه الحاديه
عشر ليلا بتوقيت المحلي لكنه مواصلوا
احتفالاتهم في البيوت وشاهدت هذا عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هنا لانه
تيليجرام او موقع تيليجرام هو المستعمل
وهو الذي يركز عليه الاوكرانيون فيما يخص
الاخبار شاهدت كثيرا كثير من التعليقات
باللغه الاوكرانيه وحتى باللغه الروسيه